now to a dramatic alleged kidnap plot by
iran to seize an iranian-american
journalist
living in the u.s massey alinajad has
been an outspoken advocate for women's
rights
and a critic of human rights abuses in
her native country prosecutors say
iranian intelligence agents tried to
lure her away from her brooklyn home
where jeff begase
spoke with alinejad jeff good morning
what did she tell you
good morning this activist has gotten
numerous death threats over the years
because of her writings and social media
posts
she told me that when the fbi showed her
surveillance photos of her
and her family allegedly taken by
iranian intelligence
that took the threat to a whole new
level
i was like wow so the islamic republic
is that close to me
even here in brooklyn and this is the
nature of the islamic republic
kidnapping
their dissidents and executing them masi
alinajad has millions of followers on
social media
where she posts videos she receives from
iranian women defying the regime
the department of justice alleges iran
directed a plot to kidnap a u.s based
journalist and american citizen
with the intention to lure our citizen
back to iran
as retaliation for their freedom of
expression
alina jade confirms she is that american
citizen
according to the indictment the
kidnappers planned to transport the
american from new york to venezuela
a country friendly to the tehran regime
and from there to iran prior to that
plot they allegedly attempted to induce
the americans relatives to lure her to a
third country
where they would extract her back to
iran but the family members refused
last night alinajad told me iranians
have gotten used to being scared of
their own government but this is the
time that
actually shows you that the government
in iran they're scared of me
it gives me hope that the government is
scared of the voice of people
because i'm the voice of people in
recent years iran has become
increasingly
aggressive about seizing opposition
journalists abroad
amid tensions over its tattered nuclear
deal
according to the indictment five critics
of the regime were targeted
i take it you're going to keep writing
oh yeah
i'm not gonna get i am not going to give
up if they arrest me or kill me
they cannot keep iranian people silent
who are fighting for freedom
we have reached out to the iranian
mission at the u.n for comment on these
charges and so far have not heard back
one of the five people indicted is in
custody the four who remain at large
could face
life in prison gail she's very brave
thank you and great hair and a bad house
too thank you jeff